question time a red zone alk a friend of
ours from across the atlantic ocean who
has been asking great questions for
years now if you're matthew stafford do
you hope and deserve to be set free from
detroit shereen your thoughts
well
mike you and i remember the curse of
bobby lane right and it's supposedly
done because the curse supposedly was
only supposed to last 50 years but this
curse continues for the detroit lions
they have won one playoff game since
that 1952
nfl championship they have longed for
the days of bobby lane and and they
haven't had it so
it is a graveyard of quarterbacks and
matthew stafford i am positive would
welcome a change a move outside of
detroit somewhere else where he has a
chance to succeed such that bobby bobby
lane got traded away and so
yeah i think he would welcome that i
don't know if that's going gonna happen
we know the cap hit and everything else
that goes into that but as a quarterback
detroit it just has not worked out for
any of those quarterbacks since bobby
lane
we know his wife would probably like to
meet leave michigan that's for damn sure
as it relates to matthew stafford though
when you've been with that team since
2009 and i remember when they drafted
him like hey the 50 years has expired
and bobby lane and matthew stafford went
to the same high school there's a poetry
and a symmetry to it and the lions are
finally going to turn around and they
have been to the playoffs a few times
but they still haven't won a playoff
game it's gotten so bad that in
2016 they commemorated the 25th
anniversary of their last playoff win
that is not something you want to be
drawing attention to detroit lions so i
i i if i'm stafford i'm ready to move on
i don't know
who's going to want him though because
it's a good question we've seen him long
enough
and
there's just you know i've i used to
call him a reluctant franchise
quarterback he didn't want all the
trappings of being a franchise
quarterback he doesn't want to be a
leader he doesn't want to be the hard
ass he doesn't want to be the guy who
demands
in a peyton manning tom brady type way
that his teammates step up and do what
they're supposed to do he's never seemed
like that guy i just don't know who's
gonna want him at this point
it could be a bridge situation mike
maybe it's one of these teams that that
drafts a quarterback high and needs a
bridge quarterback colts didn't draft a
guy high but they needed a bridge
quarterback and they they signed phillip
rivers to be that guy we know the
patriots sign cam newton as a bridge
quarterback i see him as a bridge
quarterback somewhere but nowhere long
term unless it just happens that he gets
that second chance and it happens to
work out there
he could be the next bridge in
indianapolis if they decide not to
extend their relationship with philip
rivers a second year he's a lot younger
than phillip rivers all right next
question
champ biden after tampa bay put together
an all-star team and is just slightly
above average this year they're seven
and five and they're on a buy this
weekend does jameis winston stock rise
as he goes into a free agent year you
know it helped teddy bridgewater to
start five games last year and win them
all to get a 22 million a year deal on a
three-year contract from the panthers
what does happen with jameis winston
after a year with sean payton given that
when drew brees got hurt this year it
was taysom hill not jameis winston but
when you consider the dysfunction with
the bucks do we look at jameis winston
more favorably next year
well you remember two years ago mike we
all thought teddy bridgewater was gonna
leave and go somewhere else right and
it's not like he got a ton of great
offers like he got no starting offers so
he returned to new orleans they
convinced him to return to new orleans
as a backup quarterback i could see that
happening with james swisson especially
with the way taysom hill has thrown the
ball
sean payton is brilliant and i've said
that repeatedly he went 5-0 last season
with the backup quarterback 2-0 this
season so 7-0 with the backup
quarterback that's not named drew brees
drew brees retires i could see taysom
hill and jameis winston both playing
next year for for the saints in some
capacity however they they framework
that offense but he could figure out
some way to get both of those
quarterbacks on the field and i don't
know what sean payton thinks of jameis
winston but i could see that as being a
reality i just don't know that jameis
wilson's going to get a chance to go
anywhere and start so if he's i don't
get a chance to start why wouldn't you
return and stay with sean payton
and the physicality with which taysom
hill plays suggests at some point he may
get injured which would give winston an
opportunity to play next year if hill is
the starter assuming drew brees retires
ninersforever16 asks robert salah the
49ers defensive coordinator to detroit
as head coach good choice or no salah a
michigan native last year a much harder
candidate because the team was better i
don't like that element of this
he's a hot candidate because the team is
good this year the team's struggling so
he's not a hot candidate well you know
now that they're winning some games and
their defense is playing well all of a
sudden he's a good coach again that's
just how it goes and i think he will be
on the list again this year the question
is will he get hired and also will he be
available sooner rather than later
that's one of the realities of being
with a team that makes it to the super
bowl you're not available to be hired
until after other teams would would like
to fill their vacancies
well believe it or not mike michigan
legislators you would think they would
have more to worry about with covid
going on but they have written a letter
to the lions recommending robert sala
for the job in detroit and he is a
michigan native and he went to a
northern michigan university and so i
know that's who they want but you know
it's going to be up to the new gm who he
hires and and i would assume that robert
sala will get a lot of interviews
everywhere around the league for what
he's done with the 49ers he's done an
excellent job
was there a ps on the letter get rid of
matthew stafford uh i would assume that
the powers that be at michigan may not
because of matthew though but that's
okay that's okay everyone's exercising
their free speech rights no problem with
that all right uh real quickly jaguar's
gb what direction do the jags go in
regards to their gm situation
experienced head that knows how to go
about things or a young prospect to take
the franchise in the right direction one
thing i've noticed about general
managers in recent years shireen it's
not like recycled coaches you get your
shot and then that's it and typically
teams look for the ascending general
manager not the person who's getting the
second or third bite at the apple that's
just kind of the way it's gone
yeah and i like that mike i i think you
should give somebody a chance who hasn't
had it before and there's so many names
out there that are guys that are you
know would relish that opportunity to
get that job and you know i talked the
other day i think this is the to me the
best gm opening of football you think
it's houston because of deshaun watts
and i get that they have the established
quarterback but if you go in
jacksonville you have a chance to draft
your quarterback and you're probably
going to end up with justin fields and
you have two first round picks two
second round picks two fourth rounds
picks you have a ton of cap space third
most right now in the nfl projected for
next season so you've got a lot of
things working for you to go into
jacksonville i think it's a great
opening i think you have a chance with a
very patient owner to get something done
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports